so we can say it now what can we say
Graham what what can we say welcome back
welcome back to the Gramps of the iced
coffee our right because the first time
they're gonna be back yeah welcome back
back to the non iced coffee this is old
coffee but I'm just gonna roll with it
today exactly that's how we do it here
yes so uh welcome back everyone
we hope you had a good week since the
past week what we're gonna do is first
off how was your week Graham good was it
good
good week so something crazy that
happened and it just happened today was
that Kevin O'Leary from shark tank right
reacted to your millennial money yeah
and that was pretty ridiculous yeah wise
I wish because the thing is CNBC sent me
an email the night before telling me
that like hey this is gonna happen I
think it would have been more surprising
had I just like gone on YouTube and and
had seen that and then been like totally
caught off guard wouldn't surprise me
but at least the bright side is that I
had time to prep because I knew I was
gonna be doing a reaction to that video
so at least I had time to mentally be
like okay how am I gonna structure the
next day around that so yeah it was
crazy you text me you're like dude like
all caps and I was like I was like oh my
god guys I thought first off but I was
in trouble I wouldn't if you were in
trouble I wouldn't start with dude you
wouldn't know okay good to know so yeah
that was pretty crazy
another thing is during this past week
Graham and I went back to McDonald's as
we said we would do in the first-ever
episode so tell me what happened there
Graham we did them what that's so dirty
when they say I don't want to say it but
we basically we took the McDouble young
with a McChicken and just put them
together and eat them is once that's
decent you know it's good I would say
it's good did I overact it probably it
wasn't it was a magical by any means I
mean it's exactly as you think when you
combine chicken and beef except the
thing is they've kind of a similar like
the chicken can go as meat really I
don't know the chicken has the McChicken
has a bit of a spice to it there's
something with the McChicken with it
it's in the batter or something like
that we don't even know if that's real
chicken or that's what yeah that's what
I'm saying
that's why you know I would say chicken
chickens not that expensive so I don't
know probably beef is more expensive
than chicken I don't know all right
anyways so yeah we got the we got to
make
I'll blur that and yeah it was pretty
decent and the final thing is a happy
anniversary oh is it yesterday
what Wow one year wow that's crazy
yep happy happy one year yeah yeah
congratulation survived to the first
year exactly nice so one thing that I
figured is I don't think I went to the
last podcast with enough material so I
prepared a lot for today and one thing
that I thought was insane was the Joe
Rogan thing a hundred million dollars
for what was it was the licensing for
his idea I don't know I think it was a
licensing for the Joe Rogan podcast so
only exclusively spot if I can have that
so I think what he's doing is he's
keeping it as is and then I think
September he starts doing both and then
I think by November of this year it's
gonna be just unspotted I that's insane
I'm just trying to picture my head
because I don't know what his net worth
was beforehand but waking up and just
like getting a hundred million dollars a
hundred million dollars I mean I don't
know how its structured how the payments
are cuz usually I'm guessing these deals
wouldn't just be here's a hundred
million up front it would be we
guarantee 100 million dollars a year for
the next three years
you know contingent on these surgeons
was that it a hundred million dollars
per year no sorry sir what did I know
million owes total but we're gonna pay
you sorry like you know certain amount
per year but it's gonna be a contract
worth a hundred million dollars like we
do here athletes gonna sign a 20 million
dollar contract 30 million dollar
contract it's all paid it once it's paid
right right and you think that's just
like recorded as income and just taxed
as income with state and federal taxes
just like yeah I don't know how he has
it structured and but yeah I mean the
portion of that would probably end up in
his pocket yeah that's crazy and and one
thing that it reminded me of just
acquiring that big of a lump sum at once
is that this movie called Brewster's
Millions have you ever heard of
Brewster's millionaire so it's about a
guy who was like a failed minor-league
pitcher so nothing spectacular and he
just finds out like out of nowhere
there's uncle had like a ton of money
basically and the thing was there was
like it was like a game and said if you
can spend 30 million dollars and have
net asset to zero by the end of it then
you get the rest but like the other 300
so this guy in this movie he had a month
to spend 30 million dollars and if he
couldn't spend it he didn't get the
extra 300 million but if he could do it
then he got like you know 300 million
dollars and like ten times more than he
initially got rights which was like
crazy in my mind because I saw this
movie a long time ago so I'm probably
butchering a lot of the facts and stuff
like that but have you ever heard of
Brewster's Millions
no and it's crazy to me because I think
like what would you do would you how
would you spend like that thirty million
dollars easy I would say
art cars watches real estates I mean but
then you'd have assets oh you have to
spend Oh and not have any assets yeah so
you have to have net assets zero from
that thirty million dollars oh oh okay
yeah I mean you could you could
basically we couldn't tell anyone
yes so you would be able to rent a
really expensive house there are plenty
of houses that you could rent Hamptons
the Hamptons prime season I think it's
like two hundred thousand a month you
could pay even more for like full staff
and stuff like that you could rent a
whole bunch of houses like that you're
not owning any assets on that you could
rent some really expensive a is
basically renting everything so that's
what you would do yeah because in the
movie he did a lot of things like there
was there were limitations with like you
can give away a certain amount you can't
tip a certain rights and I'm thinking
like like I might just accept the thirty
million dollars because in the movie he
was this close to not getting you would
have known you would have to have a plan
but I bet you could plan it out and
diligently you know plan to spend the 30
million bucks it's just an immigrant it
wait take a lot of time I mean it it
seems like for a month you would really
have to try to spend that much yeah
because like people came with to him
with like ridiculous investment ideas
he'd be like sure read a checks write a
check and one of them like paid off like
a ton of money like back to his thirty
million dollars so like and also at the
same time he couldn't tell anyone that
he was spending this money so everyone
thought that you know what would be a
great thing is just gamble it no you
can't you can't game no there was a
limitation on gambling okay but I'm
thinking like no one knew so everyone
thought that he was like a loser and
everyone started hating him and like he
ruined like a social life and everyone
was abusing him for his money so you
could almost buy like really expensive
price priceless paintings and then
dismiss inés oh do you damage them and
that's so much less like imagine buying
like a Mona Lisa let's just say it would
be so mad at you just you just you just
light it on fire you light on fine it
something like that and in the ashes you
sell the ashes back for let's say you
know a million dollars or something like
that and then now you only have a
million to spend 30 days you know you
could do that with with exotic cars too
you just get like a vintage Ferrari you
know ten million dollars its crash it
crash it and then sell it a mil alright
it's gotta be with something like that
and then just you know now you spend a
million dollars ma just repeat that
right but also the risk of having that
like thirty million dollars in my
opinion is enough right like I if you
put it in the market it's like seven
percents 2.1 million dollars a year so
you could live easily off of 1 million
dollars a year off of 30 million dollars
and to take the chance of not getting
anything in the end it's a lot of work I
would probably I'd probably take the
challenge but I'd find a way to spend it
fair enough fair enough
if you had ten thousand dollars to spend
in one day what would you spend I know
it's not a lot of money but that's why I
think it's an injury but I can't have
assets or I can't have assets you can
have assets tend to $10 a head spin
but you couldn't like buy it and like
put in the market or anything like that
probably buy a watch
you might wanna buy a watch fair enough
if I had to spend 10 grand a day and be
a watch if you had a higher net worth so
if your net worth was let's say like 50
to 100 million dollars and how would
what would your day be like what would
it consist of probably the same don't
say the exact same thing right because I
know you get stressed out with work yeah
but I like it so you like it's like
working out you know when you would
sometimes work out and she's like I
don't want to go work today and then you
work out you feel so much better you did
that same thing same thing with with
working making YouTube videos sometimes
it's painful to work outs of its pain
and painful arena work sometimes but
then afterwards you're so happy you did
it but would you still do like three
posts a week on the main channel in like
you know three to four on the second
channel but you still post as much I
like that because I know once they start
slipping on that the whole thing is
gonna crumble so I don't slip
would you ever spoil yourself I don't
know what what like is they don't the
aquarium honestly is the only thing that
I really want is to set up like a big
reef tank so that that would be the only
thing that I'd probably bigger one
I probably do a bigger tank I mean if
money were no issue I would probably
love to do like a thousand two thousand
gallon aquarium
and you know something crazy that's
probably what I would end up doing but
no you know there's really no oh you
know what I would like to have a place
with a garage yeah yeah yeah I want I
want a usable garage to park like you
know three cars I think my people and
love for GT like mm original five Ford
GT I think would be would be great
SLS AMG Mercedes would be another one I
really want one of those at some point
maybe a z8 BMW I think you're really
cool or like a gt3 RS Porsche or
something like I think those would be
great cars okay yeah fair enough
what do you think about having bucket
lists do you think that they're
pointless do you think that they're
worth a while to have I never really
gave it much thought do you have a
bucket list no you know what not really
I think I definitely want to do van life
at some point so I think van life is
something that I really would want to
try for like six months I think it's
really that that seems fun to me
maybe maybe like living on a boat for a
month might be kind of cool do that
traveling I do I really want to spend
like six months and just just travel six
months isn't that long I don't know so
you don't really actually have like a
bucket list per se but I mean those are
things I definitely want to do at some
point
van life I think is probably would be
sooner than later you know traveling I
definitely want to do before I'm too old
to travel so I definitely want to do
that
on the younger side of things otherwise
no I'm very very happy there's just as
things are it's amazing to me how just
like fine content you are with
everything I guess it's really cool I
asked Graham a really interesting
question which was one thing that I have
is if I wake up shoe dude was that me do
you here let me just you got to put it
do not disturb if I woke up from a bad
dream I'm happy like I'm happy that I
have a bad dream
because then when I wake up I know that
it wasn't reality and I can go back to
my reality and just be like stoked you
know but if I have a really good dream I
remember of the worst dream I've ever
had in my entire life was I had a dream
that I found 10
Honus Wagner baseball cards t 206 so
it's like and those cards were like
$500,000 so I was like oh my god of like
five million dollars in baseball cards
and I love baseball
I woke up and I was just sad I was like
10 T 206 it's just gone and it was like
depressing and I asked Graham I was like
if you have a bad dream do you feel the
same way and he said like you know he
doesn't feel the same way like he's he's
happy when he has a good dream because
he wakes up and he still thinks that is
like reality he's just it's kind of a
dismal fought but hmm I I thought that
kind of dumbfounded me I didn't think
that I thought a lot of people were
happy when they woke up from bad dreams
wait I did I never said it wasn't happy
to wake up from a bad dream no you said
that you were happy waking up from good
dreams yeah because I feel like like I
I'm excited for life so yeah so I'm
happy to wake up from a good dream but
then you realize it is in the reality
I'm happy with real you know I mean
reality's pretty good too they're both
good I think reality is just as good
okay yeah good good answer yeah for me
my bucket list would be pretty simple
Graham said that he wants or he'd like
for me to get a a Corvette at some point
funny innominate engine that's it's been
one of my um like goal cars since I was
a kid I always liked Corvettes and then
I'd also like to get a Tesla if possible
go do something impactful and to be like
you know wealthy enough would be my
bucket list politically how wealthy and
wealthy enough what is that I don't want
to have to worry about money I want to
be able to travel like you're you're
definitely but you could do that off 750
grand if you get said but I don't want
to travel like in like account you know
we wouldn't coach surf and stuff like
that like I'm a traveling nice play so
you want to be it like the Marriott and
Hilton and yeah I'll take a Marriott
I'll take a ride sure like sure I think
that like for you wealthy like I think
well you know if I was as wealthy as you
I'd be good enough like income obviously
I'd be stoked if I had your income but I
would be I would be contented
yeah I don't need like thirty million
dollars someone were given where to give
him yet like sure I have a friend that
said he would not accept like if someone
gave him thirty million dollars because
then the chase is over no he said
because he just doesn't want it he'd
know nothing about a chase he just
doesn't want to be well
like he's like I probably just by myself
like a $500,000 house and it's wavy
friends lying that's right that's what I
said I was like no way with fall no
that's what I said he was like he was so
set in his own ways that he wouldn't
want it I don't know I don't know unless
you're unless that my only thing would
be like if you give someone that then
there's no chase yeah then there's no
reason to pursue anything but you would
accept 100 million yeah I mean know what
yeah I want to see it with 95 percent
certain day it would I would be there
still 5 percent that yeah because
there's that nervousness of just what if
like you know if you take it what if
this changes things and one of what if
you know it you lose that hunger because
all of a sudden you've been fed so much
you know it is a lot more rewarding to
work for it maybe I think that for you
it's not so much about the money anymore
I think it's more about that just like
the work ethic I'm just like the drive
yeah so that could still be there if you
guys but but if you were to get $109
what would you do the next day I
wouldn't do anything for probably two
years I'd probably sit on the couch for
two years wouldn't do a single thing to
it but like not like you you would just
go about the same day like what's up
guys yeah I'm here wouldn't change a
single thing for two years dang that's
crazy
maybe a year but I would probably just
add 100 million what I'd probably end up
doing is just I'd probably put seventy
of that million into the stock market
and then maybe 30 and is buy real estate
outright at that point you just don't
need the you just it's better just take
the safe option that's what I would do I
would do probably like 10% bonds it's
like 5% like gold and silver and like
maybe 3% Bitcoin and then most of it I
would just do real estate in the rest oh
do you like stocks dollar-cost average
those what are your pet peeves Graham
really grinds your gears she's two of my
pet peeves would be littering it really
really makes me mad on people later and
people that don't say thank you when I
open up the door for them that right
there like I every single time someone
doesn't do it I just want to look at
them just say you're welcome like every
single time because I'm going out of my
way to help them yeah but you don't but
you going out of your way doesn't
necessarily deserve a thank you you go
out of your way because you you want to
help but I make sure that I say thank
you and someone else is that when I
cross the crosswalk and there's a car
going
my momma run I'll go see I just feel
like you're not you're not obligated to
receipt like if you if you want to open
the door for somebody you do it because
you want to open the door for you
we don't do it without the expectation
if I know it's nice it's cordial you
know thank you I would say thank you but
but yeah you can't be angry at someone
you do something or someone they don't
do something back
but I'm not expecting anything I mean
like I guess in a way I am but it's not
necessarily like I need to be thanked
from my own sake it's like I see them
and I view it like them as like like I'm
just like how could you not acknowledge
that it's not on me like I don't need to
receive a thank you I don't need a
compliment but what I do need is just
like to see that they're the type like
type of person that would rights thank
me okay so yeah I guess one of my pet
peeves would be just people who are
close-minded I would say that that's
that's a big one yeah without like
really get angry at people like you know
yeah saying thank you for closing very
yeah exactly but now I'd say people who
are close minded get to me because I
just I don't get it um got oh oh people
who are late
that gets me if you are late and I have
to wait for somebody I can't stand that
is the one thing that makes me angrier
than anything and I barely get angry but
if I'm kept waiting for something I do
not like it because I am always like I
want to see 99% time I'm very punctual
and I get there early so I feel like if
I make an effort to get somewhere early
if someone else shows up late obviously
if something is way beyond their control
fine
but even that you call in advance you
know as soon as you know you're gonna be
late you explain that that's that's
really fair because it's like they're
valuing their time over a war time oh
yeah they think that their time is more
important to you I forgot I just thought
of it right now that you said that is a
cutting in line
I hate line cutters yeah like if I see
someone cutting and like the snack bar
line at high school that is who they are
to me
they're a line cutter to me like I don't
even like like there are people that all
I can think of when I select pit when
someone says their name now is just
there a line cutter you know it's funny
when you say line cutting the first
thing I think of is cutting on the
freeway you know like whoa yeah yeah
actually I read a survey or I read a
study a while back that said the nicer
or the more expensive car you have the
more likely people are to let you in is
that interesting that's super weird yet
so it goes to show you like if you're
driving up in a Ferrari you want to cut
everybody or like a high-end car people
are more likely to like but do you think
that that's because they take more like
chance is that like cutting people
because I feel like people that drive
nicer cars kind of drive a little crazy
now I think it's it's the perception
that that must be someone important
where that person has status because
they have a more expensive car I'm not
gonna lie gram you're driving someone
who scares me mine I don't think you're
talking minute I think it's very scary
when I'm in the car with you I'm not
gonna say how fast you're going but
you're going a decent speed on the
freeway and it's very jerky no okay so I
say this in all fairness I think I Drive
like a grandma to be it but we get in
the car with you and it's just like
there's no urgency to get anywhere with
you it's it's driving below the speed
limit yeah if the light turns yellow and
we're like kind of there it's like well
let me just slow down and then we slow
it down like the light turns yellow it's
like five seconds yellow it's like could
it just gone I'm a passive driver I
don't I don't like tell me you compared
to you I Drive fast but I think can
compared to a lot I think I drove this
me I do drive like a grandma sometimes
yeah I will admit that yeah I get really
scared going more than seven over the
speed limit that's just where I cut it
off yeah but yeah little jerky oh yeah
that's a Tesla because that's that's the
I know yeah yeah so the number one
Google trend for today I feel like it's
it's alright it's called the mobi rrah
it's an instrument from Zimbabwe and
apparently Google does this thing called
a Google Doodle where they change the
pic the logo of Google when you do you
know www.google.com/mapmaker
[Music]
see that thing yeah it's crazy
isn't that cool I had something like
that as a kid bumping little bum thing
yeah I had no idea what that was or what
it was called I just thought it's like
this fun little thing and you'd go like
is interesting it's just a bunch of
metal bars that stick out of like some
sort of like I don't know what it is
yeah you just flick your thumb on it and
it makes and they each have a different
tune and you could just sit there just
you know flicking flicking this
instrument so it's like culture week or
something in Zimbabwe so they they made
that than them because it's like there
and that's total instruments yeah that
they're at Google Doodle so last week I
sent out some suggestions for the name
of the podcast and the winner was the
iced coffee our fall so yeah I think
that we're gonna choose that for the
name of the podcast but I'd like to say
some honorable mentions grams 20 cents I
like that I like it too I really like it
27s coffee grams 20 cents a great title
yeah thank you whoever said that yeah
that's a good one telegram okay clever
let me guess
Instagram is yeah so telega is pretty
good I like it
money talks with Graham Stefan that's a
good one I like money so isn't money
talks
oh you know what money talks is a
youtuber original series called money
yeah I didn't know that yeah I think a
few of these probably we're not like
completely the Papa Graham Graham
podcast PGP it's it's it's so makes me a
second to get that one yeah
PGG p not bad you got 20 cent power our
cool Nate I mean it Ron I like Power
Hour like you know yeah yeah yeah okay
Graham and the cracker that's funny okay
Graham in the cracker not and not a bad
one the long term the long yeah it's
fine that was probably one of my
favorites of the honorable mention this
guy Graham Stefan builds your wealth and
then in parentheses of knowledge a
little wordy it's a little wordy but I
like the creativity okay poor no more
podcast
mmm I think it's okay I like this one
the only issue is like if I was telling
my parents I bagged Oh what are you
listening to check and I said oh the
poor no more yeah yeah I don't like the
the connotation of the word poor and I
think I I want to appeal to mutt you
know the whole audience whether you're
poor or rich or whatever I'm also just
thinking of many scenarios where people
say poor no more and then people
automatically like like it doesn't sound
it sounds like poor no that's what I was
saying yeah so if my mom's asking like
what do you know poor no more yeah yeah
that might be a little bad and then
money where your mouth is a good title
yes some dishonorable mentions that I
have the lasagna in the dishwasher pot
yes to Graham in a car
grabbing 20 cent iced coffee all right
reminds me a little bit of like Jerry
sign I think that's what they were going
for with that or died dead mouse used to
do his podcast in a car really yeah what
was he doing he would driver you'd pick
up whoever he was his guest was and
usually a really high-end car usually it
was his McLaren and they would just
drive around go through the drive-thru
and that was it they would talk in the
car go through drive-thru and that's it
and it was a guest like a celebrity or
something yeah interesting so now we're
gonna move on to the next segment which
is audio submissions hi Graham I'm
interested to know what your food budget
is like for each month there you go Eden
I don't really have a budget I don't
really think about it I'd say just every
purchase I kind of think in my mind how
much that's gonna be on at this point in
since I've been working from home and
it's it's I really haven't done much I
would say my food budget has gone up
because just going and getting takeout a
little bit more often like that becomes
my thing to enjoy like I'll work all day
and then I'll enjoy going getting like
some sushi or something like that so
it's probably gone I'm probably at this
point is a few hundred bucks a month I'd
say is what it is do you think that you
fell victim to the hedonic treadmill
like at all like since I started making
more money no I would say the biggest
thing is just not leaving the house
I like splurging a little bit more now
because he it seems like a nice reward
for the end of the day all these
wouldn't be doing that if I didn't have
the income at this point but but yeah
it's just like I haven't left the house
since like for two days so like it like
last night we got the Cheesecake Factory
but so it like that's it's a small
little reward when did I leave the house
we left the house on Monday for what to
go to McDonald's and luggage in one day
so I haven't left the house since Monday
night Wow
how do you feel Graham you're still more
tan than I am I don't know well because
they work out in the backyard do you
really yeah
Oh what workout yeah oh so I don't work
out but like I work out in the backing
yeah usually I'm out there oh I am on my
computer so yeah that's why but yeah I
guess I haven't I haven't left the house
since Monday that's all right okay
yeah that's groovy but so yeah so that's
that's the reason why I think it's it's
going and getting food like that it
seems like a nice little reward since
I'm not leaving the house anyway right
plus you probably feel more compelled
just to like leave the house since
you're like stuck at home so a lot of
that's delivered just don't leave
Allison here yes but sometimes it is fun
like you know last night I wanted to go
drive to the Cheesecake Factory but to
like tie me just didn't work out for
that so I'm good okay fair enough so
there you go second submission let me
pull this up hey Graham huge fan yer I
was warning for you to another episode
of extreme cheapskates on the second
channel where you try to pick cookies in
your testicle yes that's a great idea
that's a really good idea actually um we
have not had that warm of a day like we
really gotta wait for like an 80 degree
85 degree day so when that happens yes
part of my fears that the whole car is
gonna smell like cookies for I don't
know how I don't know how you get that
smell because I'd like to smells good
man I don't I like the car the smell of
the car now because it smells like I
don't you wish cookies will like
permanently change the smell of the car
and might cuz you get you get some food
in there sometimes it just it stinks at
the car like it smells like fresh you
didn't Gramm girlfriend's car I don't
know I guess you wouldn't I don't think
she'd have a problem yeah I could do
that
if she signs I as long as she's okay
with it I'll do that yeah you do in my
car if you yeah we'll do it yeah that's
a good idea want to do that I think it's
a great idea the extreme cheapskates
thing was really interesting me because
everyone wants you to go dumpster diving
are you actually gonna do that if enough
people want it I think people do you
know like here's the thing I don't think
I don't know first of all I don't know
where to dumpster dive but I guess we
could figure that out um I don't how
clean that is I don't know if I'd to
feel comfortable eating out of a
dumpster okay I don't I didn't okay I
didn't think that we'd go that far do
you know what do you think
well back in the day there was like a
there's like a dumpster diving community
on YouTube where people like actually go
to dumpsters like I used to play video
games so I would see people go to like
dumpsters at Gamestop and they'd pull
out like fresh ps3's
okay and I'd be like are you kidding me
like that I think that they planted them
there to be completely fair they could
and like video games like actual like
xbox or ps3 games they were fine just in
the trash and like posters and stuff
that they just threw out so I actually
went one time and I went dumpster diving
there was nothing I just got dirty it
took like four hours and I had some
boxes and that was pretty much it I got
boxes like that's the thing I know
that's gonna be a long video to make and
it requires me to actually go to adult
like find a dumpster go there sift
through it clean off at like that's a
five hour long process I just I just
have to consider what my time is worth
for the five hours enjoyment of making
the video enjoyment of it yeah but
sometimes I enjoy making the main video
like the main Channel video I mean this
would be something on the second channel
so I have to consider like where I'm
gonna get that time from it's got it's
got to come from somewhere at this point
so it's it's what what am i skipping so
I could go and dumpster dive so I'm sure
it'll happen at some point I just gotta
make them well go I actually really want
to go downstairs I think that would be
fun okay this from hey Graham I'm 15 and
I've been using this quarantine period
to learn about finance and making money
but I've been wondering how I could stop
wasting so much time doing useless
things like playing video games and I'm
sure many others my age have a similar
issue any thoughts yeah you just gotta
force yourself I don't know it seems to
just like a lack of motivation there
you just gotta force yourself it's part
of part of that for me is
you got a pied the video game from
yourself like if you know you don't have
self-control don't do it don't don't put
yourself in a position where you're
gonna give in to it for me I would say a
big one would be like like having
chocolates in the house I know for me in
the afternoon I would really crave
chocolate so I purposely just won't go
and get chocolate because I know like I
don't have the self-control to hold
myself back I think it's the same thing
applies if you're gonna get caught up
with video games you got to put it away
that's fair um my old cross-country
coach told me the hardest part of going
for a run is just putting on your shoes
which I totally agree with I think the
hardest part about starting to be
productive is just taking that first
step and like making the first move to
try to do something productive to like
work towards a project and once you kind
of get into the rhythm of things it just
kind of goes yeah
from then on I could see that so yeah
just unplug and start working on
something totally agree with that and
also once you get into the rhythm of
working on it the next day getting back
into it it's so much easier like make it
a habit yep
final question hey Graham I'm from the
YouTube channel s dot minute cherry
cough cough shameless plug I was just
wondering if you'll be telling us about
how much money you make from this new
podcast of yours thank you yeah I don't
see why not least to see how this plays
out I really have no idea what do exam I
guess worst case scenario even if we
post these up on YouTube like worst case
scenario a one video a week a thousand
dollars a month
worst case I agree I would say that's
like that's probably if it if it's just
you know no one really watches or enjoys
it but I'd say a thousand a month is
probably the worst-case best-case I have
no idea it just depends who knows 100
million dollars and in three years or
whatever yeah I mean you never know but
I I would start having bigger guests on
you know like Elon Musk's like once you
start having Elon Musk's on the channel
exactly and you have someone on your
podcast and it gains like newsworthy
attention then I think that's the point
where yeah all right so now I'm gonna
ask you a couple of questions I really
like okay would you rather have no money
and three kids or no kids and three
money
what's three money which one is it
Graham I probably picked this three kids
three kids if I'm gonna be completely
broke and I had the choice I'd rather
have I'd rather see I don't understand
why people the way I took it is like
it's just a black and white question
like I think like obviously I'm 21 I
want three money and no kids but I don't
know what Levitt this is forever like is
assuming this is assuming we don't know
that if it's if it's like right now
today what do you want obviously the
three money but if it's like the rest of
your life either gonna have no money or
three kids or three kids or start no
money and I don't know why anyway the
rest of my life I'd rather have kids and
then at least they could make their own
decision if they want three kids two or
they want three money fair enough I just
see you think that it's for like the
whole duration of the rest yeah that's
how I think I don't know how I take it I
just personally I would choose a three
money no kids right now and I don't know
that's it yeah I mean but if it's right
now I picked the three money if it's for
the rest of my life I pick the three
kids okay
fair enough um is cereal a soup you
can't look this up this is a I'm just
looking define soup I wonder the
definition for soup soup okay soup says
a liquid dish typically made by boiling
meat fish or vegetables in stock or
water a substance or mixture perceived
to resemble stupid appearance or
consistency I would say this is it is a
soup well it's okay well here's the
thing
cereal itself is not a soup it becomes a
soup when you put it in milk then it
becomes a soup it's like saying you know
is is pasta a soup no not really like
ramen is not right right itself but it
is a soup when you combine ingredients
so I would say it's cereal in a box is
not soup but cereal when you add I don't
think the soup I don't think anyone was
asking you cereal in a box but I eat but
you have to clarify that like because it
could be ask a question like a box of
cereal is not in itself soup okay fair
enough I think I gonna test it
I agree with that if cereal is a soup is
a hot dog a sandwich I would say no
because really yeah no because the
sandwich you don't usually have two buns
that are connecting every time of my
barbecue hot dogs I barbeque the buns
and if you barbecue the buns they will
break apart that's a tough one I feel
like if you're one the hard job could be
a type of sandwich like you have a
Philly cheesesteak sandwich all right I
figured that burger is this you know
sandwich BLT is a sandwich then yes
actually G I change my answer yeah if
you say that you know a serials of soup
you kind of have to say oh my god dog
sandwich right would you rather fight
the final question a hundred duck-sized
horses or one horse-sized duck I've
heard that hundred duck-sized horses I
think so take is probably more
manageable I think so too yeah because
you can't fight a horse and right right
and a duck actually has like a mouth
that that yeah even really danger I
think you that's yeah I would not do
that really dangerous I like the little
tiny ones what what it was like 200
where do you think you put your limit at
for duck sized horses I put mine at 300
I don't know depends how well they're
coordinated between them because the
thing is just like you know one ant on
itself is not that you know not that bad
but you get you've hundreds of thousands
bow arrows on them and then you know
yeah how smart they are how you know
agile I don't know I'd probably if I
might might go to maybe like a I don't
know 500 I don't know 500 something like
I don't know a lot I don't know all
right fair enough
so I mean that was I thought I prepared
so much more than that was two and a
half pages in material really yeah you
know it's kind of cool right now I just
know CNBC CNBC make it trending it's not
the main CNBC but cnbc.com slash make it
I think because the kevin o'leary thank
you kevin o'leary thing every number one
yep or more number one trend day are you
kidding me well let's see what CNBC make
it so it's like they're they're offset
so it's it's not it's like CNBC trending
the main page would be like wow like
that that's like major if you want CNBC
right now trending it's like I can't
compete with how long you take before
your stimulus check arrives
president president billionaires got
Richard oh you know here's here's one
here's what we can talk about American
billionaire has got four hundred and
thirty four billion dollars richer
during the pandemic four hundred and
thirty four billion dollars yes US
billionaires saw their fortunes soar by
four hundred and thirty four billion
during the national lock down between
mid march or mid May according to a new
report Amazon's Jeff Bezos and
Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg had the
biggest gains that make sense
make sense here's they like I saw this
and it seems like they're trying to spin
it like really wealthy people are taking
advantage like this like the laws are
conditioned to be it's like the rich get
richer did that that's to be you know
instruction now they don't they don't
mention that you know overwhelmingly you
know a lot of people had their wealth go
down during this I mean you could
probably survey most millionaires or
pretty much anyone involved in the stock
market is gonna have their wealth
decline whether they're worth a hundred
million fifty million whatever the thing
that they isolate on this is it
generally to have a net worth of a
billion dollars or more usually it
involves something that scales on a mass
level it has to do with the internet
you're gonna find very few billionaires
who did so it's like you know building
you know a real-estate Empire way fewer
than you will like some thirty five
forty year old who did it with the
internet so it makes sense it just it
just so happens that during this
pandemic we all went online and so it
makes sense that a lot will have
billionaires have online stuff yeah and
so that's how they make their money so
it makes sense that they have a business
right now online that just happens to be
thriving during this time so it says to
me it's no different than you know oil
going up in price and billionaires added
money to the wall for the stock market
goes up and they could say like you know
the average American added 10 percent of
their wealth during you know these money
so to me it's nothing nothing surprising
but what I want to know is what
percentage of billionaires actually made
like a lot of money because I feel like
that would be a lot more relevant than
just saying the billionaire's made this
much because what if it's just like a
few billionaires at the top that made so
much that offset the losses of a like
some lower billionaires you know yeah
let's see because
no way every billionaire made a bunch of
money if we could figure out where the
report is I don't see any report of just
like how do we how they get the
information where do they get the
information from this is American
billionaire southern fortress or by for
a face ok according to a new report
they don't where is the report let's see
oh wait here according to the report
from the americans for tax fairness and
the institute policies for program
inequality i only i said i mean it just
sounds like they would have an agenda
yeah it seems like they're painting this
to be a negative but to me it just so
happens to me that they they had a
business that is in very high demand and
also i wouldn't expect this necessarily
to continue i mean a lot of this is on
paper as people are not going and doing
the shopping everything is online i
would expect that to come down at some
point i don't think that it's gonna
remain this high forever and i think
it's gonna take some time to catch up
after things settle down
but i think they had a good product they
had a good service that just so happens
to be in need and they're offering a lot
during this time that people use on a
daily basis so i you know i don't have a
problem with it it makes sense of like
you know Facebook and Amazon would be
doing extremely well right now though
yeah you know oh yeah of course
and and it also goes to say that Ralph
Lorenz saw his wealth drop by a hundred
million so now he's only worth five
point six billion are you kidding well
hold a wall hotelier John Pritzker sighs
both dropped by thirty four million to
two point five six but at that at that
drop is is nothing because you gotta
think five point six billion dollars to
have your net worth drop a hundred
million that's what yeah that's not
that's not like yeah it's like a bad
year in the market yeah I mean the if
someone is worth a hundred thousand and
they have it all invest in the markets
they're down ten percent that would be
yeah Ralph Lauren is down three right so
you know plus I feel like a lot of rich
people like that caliber of like well
they're probably really diversified in
their portfolios don't you think I like
they wouldn't be hit so hard by Ralph
Lauren is not sweating 100 million
loss at that level it's just that just
becomes this arbitrary number it would
make no difference at all but yeah so I
found that found that interesting that's
that's CNBC guys and then Oh what's this
kevin O'Leary reacts to a 30 year old
YouTube millionaire efuses spend money
in coffee I'm like refuses to spend
money on going his trail
I think it's one's lost time you got
Starbucks I got it as a gift for
somebody else to the guy who's been
helping us out at the nursery not like
the plan yeah or three right has been
hooking us up a lot so his request was
like hey you know if you wouldn't mind
the next time you come here just get me
a Starbucks he wanted a like a tall iced
coffee with some cream and two sugar and
I thought for fun it might be kind of
funny just to make my own coffee and get
a start ghost coming before my own copy
do the same thing and see if he notices
but but no I I went through with it I
got him a Starbucks 27 ounce coffee is
good like I remember you
you didn't really talk about it before
like we you know started working
together yeah because it came to
fruition through the second channel um
but the first time I tried it it was
really really good dude he said well a
lot of it's covered up by the by the
coffee cream right so Bobby creamer is
really where the where the flavor comes
from but it's good it's good stuff yeah
one thing I find really interesting
Graham is that you tell people to make
tic TOCs
like you advise that to a lot of the
people that are trying to grow that
really yeah why don't you do it man
I just think it's I think it's silly but
we talked today it works but like I just
think it's silly III know I barely have
the time to do what I'm doing hmm so
excuse me I need a sip of my coffee sort
something for me but yeah I barely have
this happens you what I'm doing so I
don't want to add another thing into the
mix I don't want to learn something else
at this point it's why I get I just want
to continue getting better at what I
know what I'm good at
you know I was I'd used tik-tok briefly
it's it's just you have a tattoo
audience I have a tick tock I have an
account
yeah I saw your video yeah it's just not
my not my cup of coffee it's just I
don't like making the content on there
is don't like it I eat
but it works so like I acknowledge it
works I get it it's just I personally
right now don't like it may maybe we
come back at this a few years from now
and like you know I'm not you known as
like some YouTube gotten like the grab
step in the tick-tock I I don't know but
this is not I just don't like it no
that's completely fair like did you know
it's the most downloaded app ever that's
crazy
well I heard that and I think I think
it's right that it is literally the most
downloaded app ever I would be surprised
as on Instagram no I think oh it says
it's the most downloaded app on the
Apple App Store
Oh makes sense does it yeah but
Instagram and snapchat are still in the
Apple App Store big stock becomes most
downloaded app after crossing the two
billion mark 2 billion people 20 that's
over 25% to billion tik-tok downloads I
wonder how many of those are just how
many people that is right I still think
it's probably over a quarter of the
population of like all humans why oh you
know what quarter one so it actually it
peaked in quarter four of 2018 went down
2019 and then this year so far it
exploded probably because of the
pandemic yeah I think just it gives
people a thing to do it's just another
thing to keep our minds occupied as tick
tock so I was a hater of tick tock I
didn't like it and I saw no point in it
I thought vine was better than tick tock
and I decided to get one because my
friend told me to get one I haven't made
any tick tiles but I saw it and actually
after spending a little bit of time on
it it's funny yeah I like the for you
page the main page whatever it is you
get some interesting stuff and you can't
tonight there's a lot of creativity that
goes into some of these things and I'm
like how do you do that how do you think
of that like that's really good and
interesting to see where where it
develops from there I see a lot of
people going from tick talked into
YouTube which is interesting but you
know I think whatever platform you can
you could get on is it make sense and
yeah I mean it works it's just I might
be a little
too old to jump in at this point that's
how I feel I might cut this but you know
who Jason Derulo is he's like the king
of take talk right now are you serious
he has 20 he's like 20 million followers
on tick-tock I'm like 4.5 on Instagram
Wow Jason Derulo is big though yeah but
why four times the amount of followers
on tick-tock on Instagram he makes so
many tick tocks
like so many and he's super into it I
think it's the funniest thing yeah Jason
Derulo was a bit was a big music guy
though like 10 years ago like he had a
lot quite a few hit songs and it's good
to see his continued that momentum yeah
because I don't know if I know any new
music by him but Wow way to go way to go
Jason Derulo yeah yeah all he knows
Jason yeah this is good so I think for
the next one though what we should end
up doing is let's find some news stories
that we could discuss and talk about and
that way I feel like it's less of like a
QA and it like more of a discussion that
we could talk about like current events
and let let us know down below in the
comments or reach out or do something
let us know what you think of that but I
mean that that's the direction I think
would be rather interesting but whatever
you think man I agree I think it should
be more conversational yes and QA right
based yeah I think that's a good idea
otherwise we're gonna run out of stuff
on the QA there's only so much to QA
right right that news is forever um so
yeah thank you guys so much for checking
this out this would be the second
episode yeah and you'll see the third
next week exactly so I'm with that said
that said thanks for watching guys
thanks for watching smash like button
add add us on Instagram to free stocks
down below in the description to get
Weeble Weeble Weeble get your two free
stocks
one of them's worth up to 1400 and yeah
with that said you guys thanks so much
for watching and until next time